. Let's go to our caller from the four zero
six area code.
Who's calling from four oh six today?
That's me.
Yes, it is.
Who's this good?
I believe it also was I am calling from to
make my affairs to make a call.
You are indeed the first Jamaican caller we've
ever had.
I feel so grateful for this.
Personally, I gave on to this Lethlean team
because initially because of Cairo.
And then I was drawn into your community because
I think to a certain extent, you know, a little
bit more realistic approach to progress is
progress is looming.
Then I like Heleno and I like or we like,
particularly with a team here, approach is
more realistic.
My question to you, to my question to do is
sometimes I wonder if you're too consumed
by your critique of Trump.
So sometimes you might miss way he presumes.
But it is so bad because I like to do what
I'm trying to say is less of a problem like
that.
Trump has that many people find a way to fix
it.
And sometimes I think your critique properly
addressed some of those issue.
Beautiful question.
I totally understand what you're saying.
Yeah.
I mean, listen, it's not I I'm not even suffering
from the delusion that Biden would fix all
of the problems of Trump with the analogy
I've been using is we just need to get the
ball back so we have the opportunity of putting
some points on the board and we're not going
to put all of the points on the board with
Joe Biden.
But it's it's the opportunity now what's going
on in the back?
Are you in a restaurant?
It sounds extremely loud.
They're.
No.
No, my, my, my, my mother, and it is extremely
quiet.
So is that right?
I like hot pots and pans.
Yeah.
No, listen, I mean, you're you're bringing.
I agree with you.
I take no qualms with you.
If I have given anyone the impression that
Joe Biden fixes all of the problems that are
evident with Trump, that's not the case.
But some problems would be fixed and we would
stop doing as much damage.
And and it's a harm reduction approach.
I'd make no qualms about that.
In doing so, Show is saying over there is
what I see are more economic concerns, especially
in this time, given that like, for example,
with the bailouts that more right after the
current alerts go, people are pointing to
if it was jawboning, the same team would have
liked their board.
Been to call an economic cause to learn another
culture is clearly a different and some people
are appointed.
That's not enough.
So here's where I take a little bit of issue
with what you're pointing out.
If the argument is Biden would also have done
bailouts.
Yes, Biden would also have done bailouts.
Here's what I think the difference is.
Would have been if Joe if Trump had been Biden
instead, he would have listened more to the
medical science community from the beginning
and the pandemic would never have been as
bad.
And thus it would have necessitated it would
not have necessitated the same economic reaction.
And my belief is that it would have been done
in a less crony stick way under Joe Biden
than Donald Trump.
So, yes, they both would have done bailouts.
But I think we would be far better off in
total economically if it had been Joe Biden
at the helm rather than Donald Trump.
Aye, aye.
Our industries.
Because they have a lot of callers on the
phone.
Well, that's what I wanted to.
Another question I wanted to ask is regarding
this free speech of my critique of the left,
too, is that the left is giving their aid
on a mission to to believe that the ODU, the
so-called fighters, are free speech.
And that's to an extent, me crazy because
I think some people under 18.
This is the opportunity to see where they
would really Kember's free speech.
Well, Wendell, if he saw the cancer closer
to walk, then it kind of give them on my Nishan
to feel that the.
I completely agree with you.
The entire idea or meme of the left is against
open discussion and the right is for it.
The left wants to cancel everything and the
right wants to hear every.
I think it's I think it's you're completely
correct in your analysis.
And we've got to take the narrative back.
My friend, I'm going to let you go.
It sounds like things are it sounds like the
main course is about to be served.
Thank you.
First call from Jamaica.
We absolutely love it.
And on that note, let's go out on a high.
We are going to go to a break.
I apologize.
I was not able to get to everybody today,
but we did hear from some great, great people.
And I will take calls again.